okay so let's take a break from
spider-man for a minute since we've been
covering a lot of that recently and
let's talk about donnie kate's hulk
which by the way this is drawn by ryan
otley not gonna lie it's a little weird
to see donnie kate's writing a comic and
ryan stegman not drawing it those are
the ones who did venom for those of you
guys who don't know uh it was really
really good so those guys are kind of
like a one-two punch to a degree but uh
but this is the beginning of the new
incredible hulk story arc under donnie
kate so we are finished with al ewing's
immortal hulk that's kind of a
self-contained story this one kind of
builds off of it but we may do a full
sword let me know if you guys are
interested in seeing like an immortal
hulk full story video i don't think
we've done that yet but something else
to also keep in mind is that this is a
monthly series so this will be coming
out once every month uh so we won't be
covering it like every week or every day
like we'll cover them as they come out
but what this does here is this
basically picks up with the incredible
hulk like punching against a wall which
is kind of a weird thing right it's
literally just like a giant door kind of
out in the middle of nowhere and we get
this sort of
you know exposition here right it says
things like you know i have long held a
theory about the hulk uh that i've never
shared it before because quite frankly
it terrifies me to the very core that
we've always thought of the hulk as the
manifestation of dr banner's trauma that
he experienced as a child or perhaps his
id his shadow his fury and then the
question becomes but what if the hulk is
none of those things what if it exists
to protect us from banner himself and
that's a cool thing right so one of the
great things about donnie kate so those
guys who don't know he's very very very
very good at looking at the status quo
for an existing character and then
flipping it on its head and so what you
end up doing is actually switching to
this discussion between bruce banner and
betty ross and it's kind of a crazy
thing because of course he tells you
know betty you're not supposed to be
here and she really approaches him with
this conversation about what he's doing
with the hulk that he can't simply keep
the incredible hulk locked into that
particular location now this is kind of
interesting because what donny keats is
doing is kind of toying with us a little
bit in relation to like jason aaron's
incredible hulk run and then like the
traditional incredible hulk mythos and
the reason why i say that is because as
you guys know with the traditional
incredible hulk mythos the hulk is a
manifestation of banner so they're
basically two different people sharing
the same body right like bruce banner
physically transforms into the
incredible hulk what jason aaron did
during his run on hulk is he actually
wrote a story whereby the two of them
were split so you had bruce banner in a
separate body from the incredible hulk
and that's happened over the years right
during the onslaught saga for example
the psychic consciousness of bruce
spanner was removed from the incredible
hulk in order to provide a kind of just
pure savage hulk that was really the
most powerful version of his character
we'd seen up to that point that was the
only real means to basically defeat or
at least find a way to defeat onslaught
that kind of a thing and so donnie
kate's isn't really creating new ground
here he's kind of retreading existing
ground but doing it in his own way which
is a cool thing and so ultimately
banner's response to betty is one of
hostility at least as it pertains to the
hulk that betty kind of views the
incredible hulk is very much like a
child and he really is right the
incredible hulk is very childlike in
terms of how he operates unless you're
talking about world breaker hulk or
something like that but savage hulk is
very very childlike in that way and so
what betty says is that she's concerned
about this because hurting the
incredible hulk is hurting banner and
it's one of those things where she's
like you can't blame yourself for what
happened in el paso now for those of you
guys who are approaching this from the
perspective of okay did i miss something
from immortal hulk no you didn't there
was a recent interview that donnie cates
did where he answered that question
because it was the one thing that people
wanted to know was like okay did we miss
something from immortal hulk that
happened in el paso or something like
that and during his interview with
comicbook.com he said no like it's a
thing that has not been revealed yet
it's just something that took place
between the end of immortal hulk and the
beginning of this run but whatever it
was that took place out there banner
just kind of freaks out and says he
doesn't really blame himself he blames
the incredible hulk and so ultimately
his feelings about how the world
perceives him really come out and
manifest here and this is something that
you don't readily see from banner where
betty says that like you're scaring me
right you can't act like this you don't
sound like yourself then the responsive
manner is and how would you know what i
sound like right how would anybody know
the only time i'm ever useful to any of
you all is when i'm not here when you
need the incredible hulk and he says i
never wanted any of this right i never
wanted to be a superhero or a defender
or an avenger or a monster he's like i
never wanted to do any of this stuff all
i wanted to do was push boundaries all i
wanted to be was a man of science and so
he says at the end of the day it didn't
work like none of that happened and so
because of that he says like this this
whole thing right like this incredible
hulk it grew inside of me like some kind
of a tumor some kind of an illness you
know and and i was a fool to believe
that it would ever stop growing in the
first place to believe that i could
somehow control the hulk or contain the
hulk that after the events of of dealing
with the one below all and the one above
all that i somehow had a stronger grasp
on all this i was a fool to believe any
of that but more so than that the
biggest concern that bruce banner has is
that at some point in time the
incredible hulk is going to manifest
he's going to take over and his fear is
not that the incredible hulk is going to
kill his friends or anything like that
is that the incredible hulk we'll stay
that way that banner will never come
back out again right then the incredible
hulk will basically find a way to stay
in control and you'll never ever see
banner he'll lose himself and that's one
of the funny things where again donnie
kate's is building on history here
specifically with peter david's the
incredible hulk the end for those of you
guys who never read that story it was a
phenomenal story where basically the
incredible hulk was the last living
thing on earth right we're not really a
thing he was a last living uh superhero
last living person on earth and that all
that was left after this just
catastrophic nuclear war was basically
just him and like giant bugs that would
eat him on a daily basis and he would
heal himself and all that kind of stuff
but there's one point near the end of
the story or really at the end of the
story where he lashes out his banner
who's basically grown old and he screams
at banner that like i want you to go
away right holst just wants to be alone
and then the banner persona basically
dies of old age however that works and
so because of that the incredible hulk
is eternally left alone on earth like
he'll just be on earth forever and
that'll be it until such a time that
either earth is colonized by some alien
race or life begins anew and begins to
evolve that the incredible hulk will
seemingly just live on forever as the
only occupant of the planet earth itself
unless he finds a way to leave the
important thing is this is one of those
stories that donnie kate is referencing
here and so it's kind of an interesting
thing because in the end we kind of find
out to a degree what's really going on
here when banner tells betty ross get
out of my head right like get out of my
head and leave me alone this is how it
might as well end and so what he does
here is he sits on what's basically like
a captain's chair and then he says like
these waves do not crash on me they
break on me because i i am strong and
then from there you basically switch
over to the avengers i know it's weird
but it makes perfect sense here in a
second and i really love what donnie
kate's is doing here right so the first
thing you do is you pick up with
spider-man who's basically talking to
the rest of the fully assembled avengers
and the fantastic four and the question
that's asked is like okay is anybody
else super confused about what's going
on here
and the response of doctor strange is
what bruce banner has managed to achieve
here goes beyond anything anybody has
done right that in effect the incredible
hulk becomes the single most powerful
being on the face of the planet and
here's the reason why it's one of those
things where you can kind of extrapolate
it but the idea is that when doctor
strange starts talking about this he
says that what he's built that not even
dr strange could have achieved it right
the doctor strain says he scoured the
earth searching and questioning every
mystic and omega level telepath that he
could possibly find to see if they could
do such a thing and none of them could
bruce banner managed to achieve
something that the most powerful beings
on the face of the planet were unable to
do himself but then strange says there's
no way that banner could have done it
himself that it just doesn't make any
sense the magic required is just beyond
anything and so at the end of the day of
course captain america kind of reels
them back in and says tell us what's
going on and so what we end up learning
here is that bruce banner had basically
fractured his mind into three distinct
parts and by unifying these parts but
controlling them individually he's
basically made what's being referred to
as a starship right now the term
starship is a loose term here this is
not something like the end of like
moonwalker right where like michael
jackson turned into a ship and flew away
that's not what we're talking about here
it's it's the phrase or the term
starship in relation to basically how
the incredible hulk exists right now now
the other thing about this is that the
incredible hulk is making its way
towards one degree mountain looking for
a particular thing and it's kind of
crazy because along the way he's
basically fighting iron man and four
hulk buster armors which is nuts and
he's overpowering them all but what
doctor strange tells us is that these
three distinct parts are eloquently
designed and really work as a singular
cohesive unit what banner had done first
and foremost is he had stolen technology
from advanced idea mechanics and then
basically used that technology to
enhance the skin for lack of a better
word of the incredible hulk basically
he's made the incredible hulk more
durable than he was before as if he
needed it the incredible hulk was
already one of the most durable beings
out there like being able to
successfully physically injure the hulk
is no small thing i mean you could make
his nose bleed if you were strong enough
right like the thing has done that but
if you're talking about like literally
cutting the hulk removing a limb or
something like that you need something
like adamantium possibly vibranium and
most likely something like carbonadium
or the muramasa blade in order to pull
that off you would need a highly
specialized weapon to achieve that what
banner's done here is basically push
that durability beyond what we've
previously seen with this character and
we'll actually see how far deep that
goes because it gets nuts the second
thing that banner's done is he's built
this giant mind palace like nothing
doctor strange has ever seen before so
much so that there's not a singular
telepath on earth that can get through
it no one can break through it emma
frost professor xavier of the x-men no
one can break through this psychic
barrier that bruce banner has erected in
the mind of the incredible hulk and then
following that of course you have this
kind of you know conversation not really
a conversation so much just taunting
back and forth between banner and iron
man right where it's kind of like
you can't beat me so on and so forth but
like he crushes them all in terms of the
durability of iron man this is where
things get cool so one of the things
that he does here is he basically fires
off what are basically these rockets
that have adamantium nanoparticle
shrapnel inside of them in effect what
happens these are like little just tiny
shards of adamantium they barrel
themselves into the body of whatever
their target happens to be and then due
to their nano programming they basically
forge the adamantium at an atomic level
in effect adamantium grows from the
inside out and so for the incredible
hulk this is designed to grow in the
form of a cage to basically lock him
down in place and so that's when you get
into the third thing or the third aspect
of what bruce banner's done here that
the incredible hulk itself is powered by
range right as you guys know the angrier
the incredible hulk gets the stronger he
gets what if you were able to find a way
to weaponize that and so that's what
banner's done that banner sitting in
this kind of captain's chair is
basically controlling the body of the
incredible hulk but what of the
incredible hulk's consciousness banner
has actually taken that and locked it
away and that's what you saw in that
opening scene when he was punching on
that door that banner has imprisoned the
psyche of the incredible hulk and then
basically subjects him to constant
bombardment by enemy forces whenever he
needs him to become angry and because
the incredible hulk is childlike the
incredible hulk is going to attack
whatever it is that's attacking him and
he's going to become angrier the longer
the conflict goes on because these are
basically infinite armies that would be
attacking him he would just become
angrier and angrier and angrier
basically bruce banner's found a way to
weaponize the incredible hulk's rage
that rage is the engine that bruce
banner is using so what's basically
going on here to kind of give you guys a
better perception is that bruce banner
used technology to modify the body of
the incredible hulk to make him more
durable he in turn took over the mind of
the incredible hulk and he uses the
incredible hulk's rage to decide how
angry or how powerful the incredible
hulk is going to get so basically just
imagine that at any point in time in any
fight that uh that bruce banner could
just amp the incredible hulk up to like
world breaker levels on a whim that's
what we're talking about here weaponized
world breaker hulk it's nuts and so in
this conflict because of the fact that
the adamantium is basically holding him
in place and not even the incredible
hulk is strong enough to physically
break through adamantium he actually
rips his arm out of it and when he does
it literally tears his arm off like
which is kind of crazy so he's basically
pummeling tony stark with one arm
against all these hulk buster suits
right like literally all these hulk
retro suits that he has are getting
totally obliterated with his one arm and
then he takes one of the arms of the
hulkbuster suits and attaches it to his
snapped arm right to his arm that was
ripped off and then just goes forward
from there and so what you end up
finding is that the immortal hulk
traveling here of course once his arm is
basically healed which really only took
a couple of minutes right if that maybe
like 30 seconds to fully heal which
gives you a real indication of just how
powerful and durable he is that what he
was looking for was actually something
that tony stark built project arc so the
idea behind this is that in the
aftermath of the events of king and
black when null had attacked the world
that null overcame the world super fast
right showing up with celestials
different things like that and tony
stark who is ever the futurist began
developing a kind of suit of armor that
would serve one part as protection and
then one part as basically a gateway as
a wormhole and that's why you see in its
chest is what looks like a giant portal
energy source where the arc reactor
would normally be and what would happen
here is that in a time of a massive
emergency he could actually evacuate the
world's population through this thing
now the other thing about it and those
of you guys who are x-men fans is
probably not lost on you this looks like
master mold and i have to believe
there's probably a reason for that but
what this looks like because of the fact
that tony stark piloted a celestial is
that it looks like it's a celestial
killer armor is what it looks like right
like iron man's celestial killer armor
which is kind of nuts but at the end of
the day the response of hulk is i'm
gonna need to borrow this so you know
despite tony stark begging for him not
to that the math is not complete he has
no idea where he'll go if he passes
through that portal if you'll basically
take control of the suit of armor itself
or if you'll end up in some hellish
dimension or the realm of mephisto or
the negative zone there's no way to know
what'll happen the responsive banner is
i don't care it doesn't matter to me
what i want to achieve is more important
so he literally travels through the
portal to a future destination and we
have no idea what awaits him there but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this to an end this is one hell of
a first issue i'm not even gonna lie
this is phenomenal and i can't wait to
find out where it goes man let me know
what you guys think down in the comments
section because i am hyped about this
but thank you guys for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace